PROFESSOR: We're
finished with WKB.
In recitation, you saw some
transmission across the barrier
and that's also
included in the notes.
That's an important application
of WKB and should look at it.
And today we're going to
start with a new topic.
It's time-dependent
perturbation theory.
And time-dependent
perturbation theory
is going to keep us busy
for a number of lectures.
There's a lot of
applications of these ideas
and the methods
are rather general.
Here is the place where we
will learn about Fermi's Golden
Rule.
The kind of rule that
is useful for radiation
problems, ionization
problems, transitions.
It's all very applied.
Nevertheless, we have to develop
the theory carefully and see
what are the main concepts.
So time-dependent perturbation
theory is our subject.
Time-dependent
perturbation theory.
Again, we will begin
with a Hamiltonian
that is time independent.
And we know about it.
We call this Hamiltonian H zero.
The same name we used for
time-independent perturbation
theory.
We have H zero.
This time, however, we
will have a perturbation.
The perturbation will
also be called delta H.
But the big difference is this
time the perturbation will
be time dependent.
And this will be our
whole Hamiltonian.
So this is the subject
we're trying to understand.
Whenever you have a Hamiltonian,
this time independent,
we already know how we're
supposed to deal with it.
We're supposed to find
the energy eigenstates.
And then we'll have
the whole collection
of energy eigenstates.
We can solve any problem.
In the initial condition
of the wave function,
you expand it in
energy eigenstates.
You evolve the state in time.
Everything is nice and simple.
In a sense, for the first
time in your studies
of quantum mechanics
at MIT, we're
going to face very directly
the difficulties of time
dependence.
And the first difficulty of a
time dependent Hamiltonian is
that you cannot define
energy eigenstates anymore.
The whole concept is gone.
That's pretty radical.
But it's unfortunately
the truth.
When you first learn
in 804, how to work
with energy
eigenstates, it was all
dependent on a factorization.
A possible factorization
of the solution
in the factor that depends on
position and a function that
depends on time.
And that time-dependence
was always very simple.
E to the minus iEt
over h-bar, where
E was the energy
which was a solution
of the time-independent,
spatial part of the problem.
So separating the
differential equation
was possible because, for
example, the potentials never
depended on time.
If the potential
depends on time,
imagine the equation
H psi equal e psi.
This supposed to be
time independent.
But H has a time
dependent potential.
It's just impossible.
So we don't have energy
eigenstates, any more,
for this potential,
for the new potential,
for the new Hamiltonian.
And we'll have to
think how we're going
to face these difficulties.
So no energy
eigenstates for H of t.
Of course, there are
energy eigenstates for H0.
H0 is supposed to be your
time-independent Hamiltonian.
So how do we think of this?
We will think of
time, evolving here,
and typically we will
have an initial time t0.
And throughout this region, the
Hamiltonian, H is equal to H0,
for time less than 10 0.
Then we imagine that the
perturbation turns on,
and suddenly things start
happening, up to time tf.
Here the Hamiltonian
is H0 plus delta H t.
And after, the time tf, the
Hamiltonian, is back to H0.
So that's a nice way of thinking
about the problem, in which we
imagine, OK,
perturbation is localized
that some time t
begins there before you
have the known Hamiltonian,
after you have the known
Hamiltonian.
That allows you to rephrase
questions in a clearer way,
because there are
energy eigenstates here.
If you sit at that
energy eigenstate
before time equal t0, you will
remain in an energy eigenstate.
There's no reason
why it changes.
That's what time-independent
Hamiltonians do.
The energy eigenstate
changes by a phase.
And that's all it does.
So here, we can speak
about energy eigenstates,
and after time tf, we can
speak about energy eigenstates.
So we can ask the
question, suppose
you were sitting on this
particular energy eigenstate,
here.
Then the world shakes
for a few moments.
Which state are you
going to find yourself,
after this process?
And this is a question of going
from one energy aide and state
to some collection of
energy eigenstates.
By the time the lecture
will be finished,
we will have solved this
problem in principle,
and set up how you would do
it, in practice, for any case.
This is a very physical
way of thinking, as well.
You can imagine, you
have a hydrogen atom
in its ground state.
So the original system
is a Hamiltonian
for a particle, an
electron, and a proton.
And it happens to be
in a ground state.
Then you send in an
electromagnetic wave, something
we will do next lecture.
No, in a couple of lectures.
And then, it's possible
that the atom gets ionized,
or that the electron is
kicked up to a higher level.
You will be able to calculate
those transition functions.
the probability of ionization.
In which, after the perturbation
is all said and done, you ask,
what is the
probability that you're
in an eigenstate, that
this a higher excited state
of the hydrogen atom?
And with a little bit of
flexibility in your mind,
you can think of
the hydrogen atom
as a system that
has bound states,
and continuum
states, in which you
have a proton and an
electron traveling a wave.
If you your electron is
far enough from the proton,
it's like a plane wave.
If it's not that
far, it can travel.
And its wave is
deformed a little.
Those are the continuum
states of the hydrogen atom.
So you could ask, what is the
probability that it's ionized,
and it's a transition to
a continuum eigenstate
in the hydrogen atom?
This sounds more complicated.
It's a little more complicated.
Why?
Because when you go from
one state to another,
you can count it.
But when you ask what is the
probability that the electron
goes into the continuum
of plane wave,
you'll have infinitely
many continuum states.
And we will have
to deal with that.
Where we will know--
we will not be able to
avoid this complication.
And that complication makes
for a very interesting result,
transitions to the continuum.
So this is what we want to do.
And if given, that
in general, this
is not a problem of
finding energy eigenstates,
the energy
eigenstates are known,
we want to find the
wave function, psi of t.
That's our real unknown.
And to do that, we
will use something
called the interaction picture.
Just like we have Heisenberg
picture, Schrodinger picture,
we'll have an
interaction picture.
Don't worry.
It's not more complicated
than anything you've seen.
It's, in fact, a
very sensible way
of doing things, in
which you combine
good things from the
Heisenberg picture,
and nice things from the
Schrodinger picture, together.
So remember, a little
of what was going on
with the Heisenberg picture.
It all began by saying that,
if you have the expectation
value of a Schrodinger operator,
that was the same thing.
A s for A Schrodinger, that
was possible to compute
as the expectation value of the
Heisenberg operator on the time
equals 0 states, in the
states that don't vary.
You don't need to compute
expectation values of operators
used in the time
involved states.
You can think of time
involved operators
and compute in this
expectation value
in the time equals 0 states.
For that, you use
the unitary operator,
that does time
evolution, u of t psi
at 0 u dagger of t psi at 0.
And this unitary
operator, it's in general
difficult to calculate.
It's a unitary operator
that does time evolution
and, in our case, it's hard
because the Hamiltonian
is complicated.
But in general, we call this
the Heisenberg operator.
A Heisenberg of t.
That's the definition of
the Heisenberg operator.
Another concept that
is kind of useful,
is the idea of operators
that brings states to rest.
So suppose you have the
state psi at sum time t.
I want to act with an operator
that will bring it to rest.
That means that this
is time-dependent.
I want to act with
something that
will make it time-independent.
So the answer is U dagger.
U dagger is a unitary operator,
so it's the inverse of U.
So look at this expression,
U dagger on this state
gives you U dagger.
The state is U on the
state at time equals 0.
U dagger U, being
unitary, it's just
the unit matrix, and your 2 0.
So this operator, U dagger,
removes the time-dependence.
The [INAUDIBLE]
uses the expression,
brings the operator to rest.
So we can think of doing
something of this kind.
You see, the whole Hamiltonian
is H0 plus delta H.
H0 you understand well.
Delta H is complicated.
So how about doing the time
evolution through Heisenberg,
with H0, with what you know.
You don't know the
full U, but you
know the U that
would do the time
evolution, for the
time-independent Hamiltonian,
H0.
So let's attempt to do
the part that is easy.
You see, there's going
to be time evolution
as you go from t0 to tf.
Some of that is going
to be generated by H0,
some of that by delta H. Let's
let Heisenberg do the work
for H0, and Schrodinger
do the work for delta H.
That's basically the idea. .
You see, you know that what is
difficult about this problem
is the delta H. So you solve
the Schrodinger equation.
Let's solve the Schrodinger
equation that just has delta H,
doesn't have H anymore.
So motivated by this,
we'll do exactly that.
Think of for H0, the operator
U is e to the minus i H0
t over h-bar.
This is the operator
that generates
time evolution for H0.
So we will take
the state psi of t
and remove the time-dependence
associated to H0.
So try to bring
the state to rest.
So we'll put here,
e to the minus--
I'm sorry.
I'm supposed to put U dagger.
So I'll put e to the
I H0 t over H-bar.
And look at that.
This is U dagger.
That's the kind of thing that
brings the state to rest.
If the Hamiltonian had
only been H0, only H0,
this would be time-independent.
H0 brings it to rest.
Because the Hamilton
is not just H0,
this will not be, in
general, time-independent.
But it will depend on time.
So this is a kind of a nice
wave function in which you
sort of have removed the time
evolution having to do with H0.
So we will define this as our
auxiliary variable, psi of t.
That's the definition.
It's motivated by the idea that,
if delta H was equal to 0, then
psi tilde is constant in time.
Because if delta
H was equal to 0,
all the evolution
is created by H0.
You would put here, oh, this is
e to the minus i H0 times psi
of t equal 0, the
exponentials would cancel,
and everything would be simple.
So this is a wave
function that is
going to be our new variable.
We wanted to find psi of t.
Now you can say your task
is find psi tilde of t.
That's your new task.
And it's an equally good
task, because if you
find psi tilde of t, then
you can write psi of t
as, from this equation,
e to the minus
i H0 t over H-bar
psi tilde of t.
So our task now will
be to find psi tilde.
If we have psi tilde,
we have psi, as well.
So we haven't lost
any information.
And this is all good.
So let's try to see what
equation is satisfied
by psi tilde, what kind
of Schrodinger equation
is satisfied by it.
So what is the Schrodinger
equation for psi tilde.
I'll just take i H-bar d dt of
psi tilde and see what I get.
OK.
If I have to differentiate
this term, i H-bar d dt.
I have to differentiate
this exponential.
And the i is going to
give you a minus sign.
The H's are going to cancel.
And this is just going
to bring an H0 down.
So I'm going to get minus
H0 times that exponential.
And that exponential times
psi of t is psi tilde of t.
So the derivative
of the first term
gives me something with H0.
And the face times that
is still psi tilde.
Now I have to differentiate
the second one so I have plus
e to the i H0 t over H-bar.
And i H-bar d dt of this cat.
But that's the Schrodinger
equation for the original cat.
So I should put here the full
Hamiltonian, H0 plus delta H
times psi of t.
So when the i dd
H hits the state,
you get the full
Hamiltonian time psi of t.
But I actually were right for
psi of t e to the minus i H0 t
over H-bar psi tilde of t.
Because I'm looking for
an equation for psi tilde.
I'm going a little--
I'm speaking slowly,
but going a little fast.
Now what happens?
What you wanted to
happen, happened.
H0 is here.
And look, H0 is here.
Well it's accompanied by
these two exponentials,
but they have H0.
So they commute through
and these two exponentials
cancel as far as this
first term is concerned.
So nice consolation over here.
And then we get the
following equation,
i H-bar d dt of psi tilde is
equal to, well, this delta H
sandwiched in these
two operators.
So I'll just copy it.
e to the H0 t over H-bar
delta H e to the minus i H0 t
over H-S bar times
pi tilde of t.
So this equation makes
what we wanted manifest.
If delta H vanishes, psi
tilde is time-independent.
But it's more than that.
This which we will
call delta H tilde.
So tilde objects
are objects that
have been acted by H0,
like the tilde state,
it has an H0 with
respect to the other.
This delta H tilde is because
it has been acted by similarity
with those things.
But even more, I
think you should
realize that this thing
is really the Heisenberg 0
version of delta H. A
Heisenberg operator is obtained
by taking the Schrodinger
operator, putting U dagger
and U. And that's exactly
what you've done here.
You've taken the Schrodinger
operator and put U
dagger with respect
to H0, and U for H0.
So this is the Heisenberg
version of delta H
relative to H0.
So delta H has been
"Heisenberg-ed" using H0.
And then this whole thing
looks like i H-bar d dt of psi
tilde equal delta
H tilde psi tilde.
And this is a
Schrodinger equation.
So there it is, for you, the
so-called interaction picture.
The interaction
picture says whatever
is not an interaction
will make it Heisenberg.
Whatever is purely interactive
will make it Schrodinger.
And therefore, this
state varies in time.
And there are some
operators that
have acquired extra
time-dependence, as well, due
to the Heisenberg process.
So this is the situation we
are going to try to solve.